hey guys I'm Ryan right it ought to be
crazy we're gonna check out from top
trending channel today Batman V Superman
rap a battle yes let's do this I'm going
to be actually checking out a lot of
Batman comics again one of them is The
Dark Knight Returns which features
Batman vs Superman which is inspiring
the new Batman V Superman dawn of
Justice movie so this rap battle better
be awesome it appears we have a bat
problem this is a job for Superman case
of the heroes that fly you mad it's too
bad you're just wearing an extra-long
do-rag you batshit crazy you're a
wackjob ring the bell for Alfred to
bring you a towel jackoff and take that
stupid mask off who need to masquerade
we all know what you did with all of
them Robinson your bad day oh my god
your steroid abuse aboard I defeated sod
you got beat by a luchador you and the
Commissioner yeah not natural what he
wants a boutique oh he just flashes the
fat signal and who the hell let you join
the Justice League this is a team of
superheroes just us leave run Dorothy
you ain't in Kansas no more I'll beat
your ass and picture me Olsen delete the
photos I'll break your jaw with brass
knuckles made of Kryptonite cracker
kneecap she'll be walking like a
kryptonite you go insane popping out
these grappling hooks and lasso Lois
Lane your girl totally I do all the
things you could she told me last night
that you were faster than a speeding
bullet
just accept the next day you got that
icy cold breath and still need a breath
Biggs you're in the square with me how
could you dare to be I'm about to make
this Kryptonian bow down and swear to me
billionaire when I see you I'm robbing
you don't move mister freeze poor I'm
popping here and yeah I hate that girl
she knows I'm mad at her a Riddler with
dead shots until her back splat rule
gets sent to the ER if you try me then
apply to your room and put poison in
your eye like oh you're looking like a
California raisin I'm a beast boy got
the whole crowd right now watch the
alien panic you need to take a sanic
strangle you your own cake with hate you
from The Daily Planet out double top of
Metropolis tried and true look up in the
sky is it a bird a plane or a dude your
supervisor is a pair of LensCrafters
red underwear boots that suits a
disaster Carl just Katya you in trouble
fool we'll reach in my utility belt pull
out the double Jude Batman one Batman
so only owner that one oh okay look this
rhymes remorses all the characters he
was like boom boom boom he also
referenced uh not referenced eight in
one of his things it was a freakazoid
and also Oh anyone it was really good
that's great for Superman Batman stuck
true to attacking Superman he really
knew how to get him personally
this is a rat battle man and he had
sicker rhymes too I go get Batman
Superman was all about it and you know
what Superman was like this is why
you're kind of lame I love that man
don't get me wrong but Superman Superman
has like powers here's the thing Batman
got him in obvious ways like here's
correct tonight yeah yeah he's the thing
he's weak Superman didn't earn his
powers in any way he's just from a
different place even yeah that man has
to learn he had to learn develop skills
yes I respect
that's my Batman's better because that's
why his rhymes are better because she
[ __ ] works at it I think Batman is
better but I think Superman's raps were
better anyway guys if you're near the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects I guess you can check out Alyssa
be
YouTube channel and you could follow us
on Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
periscope let's do a shout out TJ struck
us I know you Ryan
hey what's up I used to tell you in the
other rejects that you all are awesome
except for the one thing mister are you
advertise your periscope but are never
on so true oh this has made me upset in
quite sad gets my say on butthurt about
it so I think you should make up for it
by giving me a shout-out TJ truckies I
would love to give you a shout-out
elissa plus the beat it's the most
uneven beat you can bust but I'll try to
work with it hey you want me to keep
going just yeah yeah [ __ ] it
TJ I feel that you are gay I feel that
you want to say hey hey so Ryan hey
you're crying hey Ryan
he's not lying he makes you feel so damn
happy makes you feel so damn good you
should you would and maybe you could sew
down on this wonderful dude you want to
make love to Ryan right well guess what
man I'm into your site I'm coming in the
night wanna get up here kill meth like a
Batman fright I'm gonna tell you
something TJ I want you to say hey to me
the next time you see me behaving
crazily out on the streets
elissa buses beat while we do these
things in we stomping off beat and I'm
getting my sheets so wet with piss and I
want to give you a kiss track is yeah